Here the length is 12 feet and the width is 9 feet. Great work if you found
those. As always, we want to start by writing the two equations for perimeter
and area. We know we're going to surround or enclose our sunroom with 42 feet
of screening. This means that 42 must be the perimeter. The area of the room is
108 square feet. So, with area, we'll put 108. We'll rearrange this perimeter
equation to get 21 minus w equals l. We get that by dividing each of the terms
by two first, and then subtracting w from both sides. Now we're ready to
substitute. We replace l with it's equivalent expression, 21 minus w here. Then
we distribute w to each of the terms to get 108 equals 21 w minus w squared.
Next we want to set this equation equal to 0, so we'll move these two terms to
the left side. So, our w squared term will end up being positive. So, adding w
squared to both sides, and subtracting 21 w from both sides we'll get this
equation. Next we want to factor this quadratic by finding factors of 108 that
sum to negative 21. Those factors are negative 12 and negative 9. Then we set
this factor equal to 0, and this factor equal to 0. So, w can equal 12, or w
can equal 9. We know the width should be the shorter side, so we'll have this
width as 9 feet and this length as 12 feet. And as a quick check we can add up
all the sides to make sure that the sum is 42 feet, that's our perimeter. And
finally we check the area by multiplying the width times the length. Or 9 times
12 which equals 108 feet squared, our original area.